you're hosting something called the
golden trailer Awards yeah I've rolled
in trailer Awards that's what I just
said no one's heard of it apparently
well there are a lot of Ord shows out
there I have to admit never heard of the
golden trailer Awards is it what I think
it is yeah I hadn't heard of it either
it's basically it's a terrific spokesman
you are now for anything but Walgreens
yeah I mean I hadn't heard of it either
I often agree to do awards shows without
knowing what they are and this one's the
best trailers yeah cuz it's not often
the trailer is better than a film not in
the case of plot paul blart mall cop -
okay but in general yeah the trailers
can be great I don't know if you've seen
paul blart mall cop - but it's an
amazing film and you should go check it
out
are you in it no but I love it
okay but yeah so I did a lot of research
researching different trailers and I
found a lot of trailers that were great
they were snubbed this year which is
really frustrating so I brought a clip
of one of those brought a clip of a
trailer this is a real clip of a real
movie of a real movie big clip it's not
gonna come up and just be sounds no no
no this is for a movie called 2016 that
was made where it's an international
film yeah we're not sure where it was
made
i conan i think once you see it you know
that's the great thing about a trailer
you'll know all you need to know let's
take a look
Oh
and Kumar
[Music]
I know baby pick you know that's a real
trailer I have to see that movie now I
really want to see it gates like where
did the car come from I like the baby
kick just the baby good it's the worst
but best special effects I've ever said
thank you the dancers are eating that
bad I think that really so I couldn't
believe it when I saw it
Helen where's the steam for my ears
hey guess that thing is amazing I wish I
could do that all the time when you turn
it looks like you're breathing fire and
you're moving so quickly through the air
that smoke is coming off yeah that's
what it looks like that's what it's
designed to look like that clip we just
had has better special effects if we do